every success story seems to have this
sob story in the beginning so cry me a
river let me hear your sob yeah man I'm
no different one of my good friends let
me sleep on his couch in like three
months man it was crazy swings coming
out the couch man up
I know that you're not moved by the
breath of praise everything's mapped out
you have everything exactly as you
intended it everything is as its
supposed to be I understand that I just
I don't understand why nothing
I've been out here seven years been here
seven years when I came out here you
know that I was so wide-eyed I wanted it
so badly I was so passionate so excited
and I wanted him more than anything
I've worked hard and it hasn't
it is this is paid off
I really need some answers
hello hello hello
remember me
so I'm taking off
I just wanted to talk to you one more
time before I leave
and I wanted you to know that I tried
okay
yogi
are you in a while oh you know just
wandering around in my car you know me I
like to drive yeah I'm just heading out
to the back cuz Glenn's working so would
you thank you Jeff a second - shall we
make it my friend come on baby
so are we celebrating not what
so so Charles met with the industry
group on Monday I'm not a part of it in
any way
you're joking with me right I'm sorry
I know I know it's completely fun this
was the deal this this week I mean you
were gonna put in a new bathroom and
they were gonna pay off the card
we can't go another month just milking
this deal we can't actually do three
more months we'll take three months out
of our savings we'll be fine
now and you just let Charles get away
with this
howdy-doo two men
how was your weekend a little bit how
are they doing they're good they were
like number two well before Jesse doing
what house you're dead
we play golf like what four months ago
I'm not doing like golf season start but
I'm imagine sorta playing golf yeah III
hit so many balls as a kid that it's
like riding a bike now well go out and
shoot 75 without blinking an eye
what your dad was like your dad didn't
know how good I was until I got out in
the course yeah how's your mom I love
your mom no mom doing great did you call
her on Mother's Day I did I sent her an
email and I father so wow she's lucky
yeah yeah
like there's just perfect one up there
ever like I want that one gnarled the
ones closest are all gnarled and that
one's perfect well because if you don't
have to work for it it doesn't move much
Oh is your fault there's nothing to talk
about
I got a drop-by yeah yeah is it cool are
you guys getting a car yeah that's here
yeah absolutely
all right whatever you got wine great
thanks
hey sit down what brings you here um I
was in the neighborhood had an audition
down the street
let's treat it's a tree like trees where
you get it where you going
oh let me take this pink you okay he's
stealing your apple juice what you gonna
do about that this is good apple juice
well you can are you gonna get it oh you
wanted me to look ready and the one the
two three four five make me a cake me
give me some asparagus I'm good I'm good
so what do you have to smear what's
going on
alright man you see Bobe
you